si je vous parle de combi de vol the
game ça vous fait penser à quoi mais moi
ça me fait penser à ça et ça c'est quoi
ça c'est un t1 et le terrain gelé
conduit pendant longtemps pourquoi
lorsque j'avais animé l'émission pour
amazon ça va cartonner et j'ai fait un
road trip dans toute la france à bord du
terrain sauf que le terrain c'est une
vieille histoire des années 70 c'est
qu'aujourd'hui et bien volkswagen lui
raconter toute nouvelle histoire avec
lazy bones la guibole c'est ça c'est un
combi nouvelle génération connectée 100%
électrique alors ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui c'est faire le tour on est
au mois de janvier 2022 on est assis
jesse pas très loin de barcelone en
espagne ont bien faire un tour on va
découvrir ce véhicule 100% écrite ce
combi son conseil tricolore c'est
vachement intéressant parce que ça fait
très jolies promesses quand vous pensé
combien vous pensez quoi on pense grands
espaces on pense évasion on pense balade
on va regarder si on peut se balader on
va regarder si on a de l'évasion on va
regarder si on a du rêve avec l'ail du
buzz devant les menaces que c'est beau
alors vous inquiétez pas c'est près les
finitions que vous aurez avec ce côté un
peu et bref loin des contraintes
aujourd'hui on a une heure pour aller se
balader saint véhicule qui est camouflée
on peut pas tout vous montrer et en plus
on a interdiction de vous montrer le
tableau de bord donc tout ce qui va être
connectivité mais je peux pas vous le
montre aujourd'hui pour nous après quoi
deux grands espaces à parler d'esprit de
volkswagen va regarder ce qu'on peut me
rendre à regarder les idées et dans un
premier temps on va faire un tour alors
il y aura pas de go pro sur la vôtre
y'aura pas devant tout ce qui sera posée
là mais regardez on a vraiment un look
est super cool voilà à quoi ressemble la
i10 bosse à l'arrière
allez on va avoir de la place là on a
plusieurs versions qui vont exister là
c'est une version avec trois places à
daria mais on peut la voir en version
utilitaire c'est d'ailleurs peut-être
par là que volkswagen va arriver sur ce
nouveau marché en tout cas de
l'utilitaire électrique dans l'idée un
des grands espaces alors regardez on
leur tape ses goûts et tout seul ce que
j'aime bien ce que je trouve vachement
cool c'est ce côté un peu futuriste
qu'on va retrouver au niveau des phares
à led il ya un côté qui est vachement
sympa et un look elle file qui rappelle
l'évasion qui rappelle la grande balade
donc on va se faire un tour complet on
va et se balade aujourd'hui on va
découvrir les dix besoin là on n'est pas
là dedans on est là dedans on va se
balader et puis audrey pourquoi la halle
et plus petites heures type banane vite
fait et après on s'en glorifiant s'en
aller c'est partie remise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec la conduite elle est cool alors là
j'en attends le temps d'un rond point g
parrot partir en fait avec mon pote les
olé qui est en train de filmer on doit
toujours y avoir quelqu'un devant les
organes à côté mais comment le tour du
rond point on peut le faire lorsque vous
parlez un peu de confort de conduite à
brac l'angle de braquage il est dingue
on a ce qu'il faut c'est vrai qu'on
l'ait sur l'électrique et du couple
après spam à qui vous parlez de
motorisation électrique a très
clairement il ya des chaînes
spécialisées il ya des médias
spécialisés puisque juste vous parler en
termes de sensations ben on se sent
effectivement dans les cultes et quand
même grand enfin on sent qu'on a de
l'espace on sort les grands espaces et
on se sent bien ici donc on va peut-être
pas vous aider un des masses mais c'est
une première sensation c'est un premier
j'ai une petite heure franchement c'est
frustrant parce que j'aimerais pouvoir
faire plus j'aimerais pouvoir aller plus
loin mais on peut pas mais mais mais
voilà j'aime bien l'idée l'idée plutôt
sympa empressé pas parfait 1 j'attends
de voir toute l'expérience tableau de
bord collectivités on se trouvant à bord
d'un véhicule de volkswagen jeu pas hier
standard c'est pas vrai mais un beau
véhicule de votre gagnon n'a pas de
conduite à terme ça peut être un peu un
peu qu'on peut peut-être qu'il aurait
fallu ici puisque les soins de la
connectivité c'est de l'ambiance
volkswagen c'est un beau véhicule
volkswagen c'est des belles finitions
volkswagen maintenant est-ce que j'ai
l'impression d'être dans un combi ben
non parce que pour moi les vieux combi
ça reste ce truc là mais ça c'est hyper
dur à conduire je vais vous dire c'est
une vraie galère absolue donc l'achat
d'un véhicule de 2022 que je conduis
très bien dans lequel je me sens bien
avec ce côté combi il faut voir si on
arrive à se l'approprier il faut voir si
on peut partir se faire des balades
pendant des heures dans des plaines dans
des territoires a perdu surtout ça la
vraie question mais sinon autant de
l'expérience de conduite moi je veux ça
vachement cool c'est sympa c'est
chouette à bien s'en va avec on s'en va
ça va gueuler
volonté on le prend pas la caf à
s'entraîner sur deux roues aller où
[Musique]
les seuils à tous que je trouve vraiment
gêné alors la conduite est sympa telle
électriques ont connu on aime bien il ya
du coup ça marche ok ce qui est dingue
c'est l'angle de braquage regarder sous
mon sabre acmé de ouf juste dingue je
suis moi les gars travaillent vraiment a
ajouté je vais t'écraser garde à temps
là je croyais pas voilà je vois là je
braque regarde comme ça brac partie de
ton sens grenoble c'est dingue ça fait
notre tour
[Musique]
ce sauvetage pas mal indiqué que
volkswagen a ici d'arrivée avec l'idée
du combi effectivement le combi c'est
quoi bein c'est le véhicule de légende
on l'a tous eu alors après on se dirait
hockey les grands espaces véhicules de
légende ça marche mais pour autant je me
vois pas forcément partir tu en sais
rien moi en californie faire un road
trip vers la route 66 ça pour être ou
mais je me dis où est ce que je vais
recharger sk de la recharge aujourd'hui
alors effectivement ici en europe pour
aller me balader d'un point a à un point
b en france je sais que j'ai pas de
souci il ya de plus en plus de bornes de
recharge et des réseaux de recharge ça
va je suis rassuré mais pour autant
est-ce que l'idée des grands espaces des
deux parties ray lamontagne loin de tout
m'isoler d'envoyer un enjeu est ce que
ça va le faire avec l'électrique alors
peut-être de plus en plus peut-être dans
les temps à venir mais ça que tout de
suite je me pose encore la question
est-ce qu'il ya assez de zone de
recherches parce qu'on n'est pas sur
n'importe quelle voiture là là on est
sur le véhicule pour aller s'évader on
est là partir on se dit ok chéri on
prend on ferme on va se balader on part
on s'en fout on se trouve un coin paumé
mais où est ce que je la recharge c'est
ça en fait alors je sais qu'il ya plein
de bonne de recharge mais je me dis que
dans certains très grand espace un peu
paumé il ya peut-être falloir
s'organiser un petit peu et être un peu
moins la hache c'est un peu le truc
aujourd'hui après ce que je trouve
vraiment cool avec ce véhicule là c'est
qu'on a ce look and feel de point de vue
extérieur donc pas une guitare year ça
marche aussi c'est très sympa alors je
risque pas vous montre le tableau de
bord la collectivité c'est pas possible
nous ont quand même fait un truc assez
sympa vous avez un grand écran de 12
pouces centrale vous avez aussi un petit
écran devant vous et ses obligés de
l'avoir pour voir à quelle vitesse je
roule vous avez cette prise usb c'est
partout dans le véhicule il y en à côté
passager il y en a un côté conducteur il
y en a aussi de venger un pack de
rechargement sans fil pour me recharger
mons partant de réduction et à l'arrière
j'ai également de l'usb 5-1 définira je
vais vous montrer
j'appuie ça souffle tout seul alors déjà
il ya peu qui est très sympa c'est ce
côté là tablette saliha que je prends au
plat j'ouvre ma petite table est donc là
j'ai mon petit truc je peux monter ma
table est donc là la fin de ma petite
boisson j'ai mon sandwich super n'a donc
on est dans l'esprit campeurs on est
dans l'esprit je pars donc ça c'est
vachement bien pouvoir trouver également
des rangements la première poser ses
affaires on est pas mal alors y'a du sbc
on cherche de tous les côtés donc on est
dans un côté connectés après c'est vrai
que de ce que je vois je me dis c'est
connectés c'est bien est-ce qu'ils vont
assez loin je sais pas on attend d'avoir
effectivement la version définitive du
véhicule mais en tout cas envoyé ces
trois vraies places à l'arrière je suis
plutôt pas mal assis il ya une version
utilitaire vous avez effectivement pas
ça vous avez beaucoup de place et on ira
stocker tout ce dont vous avez besoin
c'est plus de visage professionnels
alors laissons usage familial alors tout
de suite on n'a pas le tarif de ce
véhicule je sais pas du tout à combien
il va sortire j'imagine relativement
cher il va être officialisée début mars
2022 et on pourra ensuite pour une marie
savent pas quoi ce sera septembre 2020
donc on est au tout début d'une nouvelle
histoire du combi volkswagen qui revit
en version 100% électrique et dans
l'idée c'est assez marrant georges de
montclar y avoir il ya un coffre aussi
bien c'est sympa les coffres aura
puissants se referme pas magique on le
voit ici la hype you light donc on est
effectivement dans un truc qui est très
sympa que j'aime bien c'est tout ces
blocs optiques on va retrouver avec des
éclairages led
magique donc là c'est pareil en termes
de capacité de rangement vous avez de
quoi faire donc si on se dit ok je veux
emmener le nécessaire pour aller camper
pour aller me balader un croix klein on
peut y aller est ce qu'on va mettre la
planche de surf on peut mettre la
planche de surf est-ce qu'on peut mettre
le cai on peut mettre le cas confirmés
dont vous avez du rangement de tous les
côtés tous les niveaux que ce soit pour
la famille et les amis globalement il ya
ce qu'il veut
[Musique]
quand on veut partir en camping en week
end mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et
ben on peut tout faire on peut venir
installer un lien peut venir dormir ici
regardez c'est très très facile on fait
quoi on a une petite poignée et on vient
à coucher le siège ici jusque là tout va
bien on ouvre de l'autre côté la porte
et on fait exactement la même chose ici
là je viens à coucher ça donc ça c'est
cool j'ai mon client est là qu est ce
que je fais eh ben je vais m'installer
dans la petite voiture alors sans
matelas ça va être sympa mais c'est pas
le plus tout le plus dingue j'installe
un petit matelas je suis peinard voilà
je fais quoi je vais me poser là alors
avec un match référence et là je me cale
à la belle étoile alors ils perdent
étendu dans l'oeil du buzz je peux venir
dormir donc là y'a un truc qui est
vachement cool si l'idée une fois de
plus des grands espaces et l'idée de
prendre son véhicule c'est l'idée de
partir on installe son matelas on met la
petite table mais les petites chaises
ont fait un petit feu ou parce qu'on n'a
pas envie de [ __ ] le feu partout mais
en tout cas on est bien on met petit
réchaud on prend la poêle et puis on
fait cuire les saucisses 1 ou alors les
galettes de légumes comme on veut on
peut donc ça c'est cool et c'est ce que
jamais dans l'idée une fois de plus ce
qui est vraiment venu faire ici
volkswagen avec son ami buzz c'est
recréer l'ambiance du combi alors pour
l'instant on l'a vraiment sur véhicules
soient utilitaires soit ici en 5 places
mais peut-être je sais pas j'aimerais
bien en tout cas qu'à l'avenir il vient
de faire la même chose mais avec un
petit van aménagé ça pourrait être cool
on peut toujours rêver puis on verra tel
qu'il est peut-être qu'ils le feront
j'en sais rien en tout cas c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est ce qui est intéressant ici parce
qu'on a un véhicule qui va tout le temps
connecté connecter à quoi à vos
smartphones grâce à une application vous
allez pouvoir la préchauffé avant de
partir dès lors qu'elle fait froid si
vous partez de chez vous et l'évidence
si vous êtes un roc trip pas besoin de
faire ça vous serez déjà dedans mais si
vous êtes chez vous vous dites ok il
faut partir tout organiser mon heure
départ bref c'est l'électrique comme on
connaissait sur les 10 4 et sur d'autres
véhicules électriques d'autres marques
mais il n'y a pas grande nouveauté je
vous donnais les dimensions ça vous
intéresse la largeur elle fait un mètre
1,98 à la hauteur on est à 1 93 la
longueur on est à quatre mètres 71 ok
c'est plutôt pas mal on a un moteur de
kilowatts bien évidemment comblé sur
l'électrique dont un centre de gravité
qui est très bas donc ça c'est bien et
ça tient la route on est sur une plate
forme est mauvais les roues c'est du 21
pouces gros c'est bien en termes de
techno si on marque est intéressante on
a le park assist il va venir mémoriser
en plus et bien votre habitude là vous
allez venir vous garer comme ça il vous
assistera directement pour venir vous
garez c'était toujours au même endroit
et que c'est un petit peu galère et puis
c'est pareil vous avez une assistance à
la conduite enfin bref tout ce qu'on
doit attendre aujourd'hui ta véhicules
connectés en 2022 un autre qui est
intéressant c'est le plug in charge
c'est-à-dire que lorsque vous arrivez
sur des bornes et notamment les bornes
unity vous devez arriver vous plaignez
vous avez votre carte et c'est parti là
vous avez un truc est pas mal c'est le
plugin chars vous arrivez vous prenez
vous branchez la bande de charge de
communiquer directement avec votre
véhicule et ça va lancer la charge
directement en vous débitant sans votre
compte sans vous ayez besoin d'avoir une
petite carte pour le faire un peu comme
foutais là donc voilà ça c'est bien et à
notre qui est cool et qui va aussi dans
le sens de l'histoire et même des villes
connectée est bien c'est que vous avez
de la recharge bidirectionnelle qui va
dans un sens mais également dans l'eau
c'est à dire que lorsque votre véhicule
est chargé à 100% et qui est toujours
branché à votre borne chez vous et que
vous avez besoin d'énergie pour autre
chantier vous pourrez dire prendre la
batterie votre voiture qui elle se
rechargera plus tard la nuit ça peut
éviter les pics de consommation au
niveau des villes notamment en hiver et
lorsque ça a bien consommé énormément au
niveau de centrales donc se mettre un
tout qui est aussi intéressant et qui va
dans l'histoire dans l'écriture de la
ville du futur alors ici on n'est pas
sur un véhicule qui est fait pour aller
très très vite en terme de vitesse ont
fait du 145 km heure maximum on n'est
pas là pour faire des pointes et puis de
toute façon on peut pas rouler plus vite
ça sert à rien et on a une batterie si
je le dis c'est sur mon petit calepin on
vient d'avoir les infos assez tout juste
et tout frais de 77 kilowattheure
[Musique]
f tous et à guy buzz est intéressant
alors de ce qu'on en voit là et on n'en
voit pas grand chose parce que forcément
toute la collectivité cachette ce que
j'aime bien c'est light j'aime bien
cette forme retrouvée termignone elle
est sympa et les jolies même si la
pointe envoyé là encore qu'à boufflers
elle est très agréable à conduire bien
évidemment c'est une belle électrique et
là dessus on sait que volkswagen
maîtrise et on l'a vu avec la i10 quatre
ans avec plein d'autres modèles
électriques donc là-dessus il n'y a pas
de problème du côté de josiane
maintenant ce qui est intéressant est ce
qu'on regarderait ce qu'on verra
probablement plus tard c'est quelle
histoire sarah qu'on y est ce que ça
tient la promesse d histoire que ça
raconte pas ce que c'est vraiment l'idée
de l'évasion c'est l'idée de la balade
c'est l'idée de l' aventure donc est ce
qu'on peut vraiment partir à l aventure
surtout la question de la recharge la
question du réseau du maillage ça ça
dépend pas de vol à genk mais c'est
pourtant la promesse qui est fait ici
c'est l'aventuré ce que je veux partir à
l'aventuré on le verra moi je pars à
l'aventuré à une baigner il fait beau il
fait chaud donc cette aventure là on
n'en parlera plus tard la même continuer
la vivre ont parfois pas la balle et
on en profite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]